Transcriber: Hamzeh Koumakli
المدقّق: Aya Aj
أتى رجلٌ إلى النّبي عليه الصّلاة والسّلام،
وقال: "أوصني يا رسول الله"
قال: "لا تغضب"
قال: "أوصني"
أو كما قال عليه الصّلاة والسّلام.
لماذا قال "لا تغضب"؟
ولماذا كرّرها ثلاث مرّات؟
وليس مرّة واحدة
لأنّها الحالةُ التي يفقد فيها الشّخصُ
التّحكمَ بانفعالاته وتصرّفاته،
الحالة التي لا يحسب فيها الشّخص
حساباً لردات فعله على ما يحيط به،
ويخسر عندها من رصيده العاطفيّ لدى الآخرين
دون أن يشعر.
كم مرّةً تصرّفنا تصرفاتٍ
ندمنا عليها لاحقاً،
بسبب انفعالات غير محسوبة؟!
كم مرةً جرحنا أشخاصاً أعزّاء
وغالين على قلوبنا
بسبب الغضب؟!.
ومن المؤكد أنَّنا -أكثر من مرة-
فقدنا اتّزانَنا وثقتنا بأنفسنا
وبالأشخاص من حولنا بسبب بعض المواقف
أيضاً بسبب الغضب.
إنَّه شكلٌ من أشكال التواصل
الذي نصادفه يومياً.
فكرتي اليوم
هي عن الرّصيد الائتمانيّ العاطفيّ
دعونا نتخيّل أنَّ كلَّ شخصٍ
هو بنكٌ من العواطف،
وهذا البنك لديه صناديق ائتمانيّة
لكلّ الأشخاص الذين يتعامل معهم
وحسابات ائتمانيّة لكل
الأشخاص الذين يتعامل معهم،
وهذه الحسابات والصناديق
إمّا أن تزيد وإمّا أن تنقص
إمّا أن تزيد بشكل إيجابي،
أو تنقص بشكل سلبي،
وذلك حسب التعاملات التي نقوم بها.
نُخطئُ فيُحذف من الرّصيد،
نقوم بأمرٍ جيّد فيزداد رصيدنا
لدى هؤلاء الأشخاص
حسناً، كيف يمكن أن نزيد رصيدنا
الائتماني العاطفي لدى الأشخاص من حولنا؟
ونبقيه مرتفعاً جداً دوماً؟
كي نستطيع أن نحقق هذا الأمر
يجب علينا أن نعمل دوماً على تطوير
قواعد التعامل لدينا
وكيفيّة التعامل مع الأشخاص من حولنا
وتطويرها باستمرار وتعلّم كلَّ جديد.
مثلاً القاعدة الذهبية في التعامل هي:
"عامل الناس كما تُحب أن تُعامل"
بينما يوجد قاعدة بلاتينية هي:
"عامل الناس كما يحبون أن يُعاملوا"
صديقي الذي شرح لي هذه القاعدة
كان ظريفاً جداً
قال لي:"أنا لا أحب زيت الزيتون أبداً،
ووالدتي تعشق زيت الزيتون،
فكانت كلّما تحضّر لي شطيرة لبنة،
تُكثر من وضع زيت الزيتون فيها،
فلا أعرف ماذا أفعل بها
إذ كنت أحاول التّخلص منها بأي طريقة"
حسناً، إذا كانت ترغب
في أن تحضّرها كما يُحبُّ
لما وضعت له فيها زيت الزيتون
لبنة فقط.
القاعدة الذهبية التي تكلمنا عنها،
تبقى قاعدة ذهبيّة
وبإمكانها أن تمنحنا
رصيداً عاطفياً عالياً لدى الآخرين
ولكن يوجد ما هو أفضل من ذلك
مرةً كنتُ خارج البلد،
ذهبتُ ومجموعةٌ كبيرةٌ من الأصدقاء إلى مطعم
دخلنا إلى هذا المطعم متأخرين عن وقت العشاء
عندما وصلنا طلبنا الطعام،
وطلبتُ وجبةً كنتُ قد اعتدت عليها
لكنّها وجبةٌ معقدةٌ وتحتاج إلى تجهيزٍ مسبق
بعد أن طلبنا الطعام وانتظرنا
وبعد نصف ساعة تقريباً
وصلت طلبات كل المجموعة
وجاءني مدير المطعم
وجلسَ كي يصبحَ مستوى نظره
مماثلاً لمستوى نظري
بحيث لا أرفعُ رأسي كي أنظرَ إليه،
استغربتُ حينها ولم أفهم ما الذي يريده
قال لي: "نعتذرُ منك كثيراً ونحن آسفون
ولكنّ طلبك يحتاجُ تجهيزاً مسبقاً
وكان يجب علينا مسبقاً
أن لا نقبل هكذا طلب
وحدث خطأٌ في ذلك معك"
أجبته: "حسناً -بكلّ بساطة- ما المشكلة؟!"
فقال: "أتفضّل أن تأخذ ذلك الطلب نفسه
أو طلباً آخر كأصدقائك؟"
قلت: "بل أريد هذا الطلب بالتحديد
حتى لو استغرق وقتاً أطول
فأنا مستمتعٌ بالجلوس
ولا مانع لديَّ من الانتظار"
فذهب ثمّ جاء الطلب
وكان بالفعل شهياً جداً ولذيذاً.
وفي آخر الزيارة،
تفاجأت بمدير المطعم قادماً إليّ مرة أخرى
وقال: "كلّ طلباتكم-بسبب الخطأ الذي حصل-
مجانيّة، بالإضافة إلى طبق من الحلويات"
عندها رغب أصدقائي ألّا أعود إلى بلدي
وأن أبقى معهم وأذهب معهم دوماً إلى العشاء
حسناً، هذا الشخص فاجأني
بمستوى خدمة فوق المتوقع
فبنى عنديَ رصيداً عاطفياً عالياً جداً
جعلني زبوناً عنده مدى الحياة
وأحكيَ هذه القصّة، على الرغم من أنّها
حصلت لي منذ أكثر من 16 أو 17 سنة
بالمقابل، ذات مرّة كنت جالساً في المنزل
وإذا بي أسمعُ صوتَ ماءٍ يتساقط من الأعلى
على الغسيل الذي نُشر لتوِّه
أي قبل دقائق
خرجت غاضباً أريدُ أن أتصرّف حيال هذا الأمر
عندما خرجتُ، وجدتُ أنّ الشخص
الذي قام بهذا العمل هو ابن جاري
والذي كان قد بنى لديّ
رصيداً عاطفياً عالياً جداً
وذلك جعلني أتوقف ولا أقوم بأيّ تصرّف
لأن هذا الشخص لديه مسبقاً
رصيدٌ إيجابيٌّ عندي
حسناً، كلامٌ جميل
ونستطيع جميعنا أن نقوم
بذلك في تعاملاتنا اليومية
هل نستطيع أن نقدم ما هو أكثر من ذلك؟
طبعاً، بإمكاننا ذلك
وطبعاً نستطيع أن نطوّر أكثر
وطبعاً نستطيع
أن نفهم الأشخاص من حولنا أكثر.
يوجد العديد من الاختبارات
والنظريات على الانترنت
والتي..
تتحدث عن كيفية فهم الأشخاص والتعامل معهم
وعن كيفية فهم شخصيّتك
وشخصيات الآخرين من حولك
مثل نظرية الألوان السائدة في الشخصية
ونظرية عملات التبادل الشخصي... الخ
الكثير من هذه النظريات
ولكنّ المهم هو أن نبذل جهدنا
في تطوير قواعد التعامل لدينا
هل من فائدة في ذلك؟
طبعاً، وسنرى ذلك بعد قليل
حسناً
كي نستطيع أن نفهم
هذا الضغط النفسي على المحيطين
وأن نتواصل معهم بشكل أفضل
يجب أن نفهم أنَّه كما أنّني مضغوط
وكذلك أنتَ وهو وكلنا مضغوطون في هذه الحياة
وخصوصاً بعد الذي حدث لنا هنا
الأزمة والحرب التي مررنا وما زلنا نمرُّ بها
ليست أمراً سهلاً تحمُّله على أيٍّ منّا
الكثير من الأشخاص فقدوا أناساً وأحبّة
أو ربما فقدوا شيئاً جسدياً
أو مادياً أو معنوياً
أغلبنا فقد الكثير من طموحاته
تحطّمت أحلامهم خلال هذه الأزمة
عواصفٌ من السلبيّة
والاكتئاب عِشناها جميعاً
وهذا الأمر لا يسمح لنا
أو بالأحرى لا يجب أن ندعه يؤثر علينا
لدرجة أن نخسر الرصيد العاطفي
الذي بنيناه عند الأشخاص من حولنا.
هل نستطيع أن نقلب الرصيد السلبي
لدى الأشخاص من حولنا إلى رصيد إيجابي؟
هل نستطيع أن نبدّلهما؟
هل نستطيع أن نقلبه رأساً على عقب؟
من سلبي إلى إيجابي؟
هذا ممكن وبكل بساطة
كلّ ما نحتاجه هو أن نتواضع
ونتواصل ونفصح عمّا في قلوبنا.
يوجد أيضاً العديد من الأعمال البسيطة جداً
تكلفتها منخفضة ولكنّها تمنحنا
رصيداً عالياً جداً لدى الأشخاص من حولنا
مثل الابتسامة والتحيّة،
في مجال عملي بخدمة الزبائن الطويل،
لم أشاهد في حياتي زبوناً غاضباً ومنزعجاً
جداً دخل على موظّف يريد أن يفرّغ غضبه
واستقبله الموظف
بابتسامة صادقة وتحيّة حقيقية
وبقيَ هذا الشخص غاضباً ومنزعجاً
من المستحيل أن يحدث ذلك مع أي شخص.
الاستماع والإصغاء،
في كثيرٍ من الأحيان،
يحتاج الأشخاص من حولنا فقط إلى شخصٍ
يجلس معهم ويستمع ويصغي لهم
حتى لو لم يمتلك حلاً لمشاكلهم،
الاستماع والإصغاء
يكفيان في كثيرٍ من الأحيان.
من المتعارف عليه دائماً،
أنّ ما يُقابل المُعطي هو الآخذ
ولكن إذا أردنا أن نطوّر تعاملاتنا
فإنّ ما يُقابل المُعطي هو المُستقبل،
وليس الآخذ
إنها شيءٌ بسيطٌ جداً
كما أنّها ليست بالأمر الصّعب.
في النهاية، أقول لكم: إنّ من يعيش
للآخر فإنه يعيش لذاته
في بداية الأزمة، تتطوعت في إحدى
الجمعيات الخيرية التي تعمل في حمص
وذلك دفعني للقيام بأمور بسيطة
كالتّسجيل أو العمل في فريق كشف
وأحياناً النّقل والحمل أو أيَّ شيءٍ آخر
ورويداً رويداً تعمّقت أكثر في ذلك
واندمجت في هذا العمل
وهذا الأمر مكنني من التطوّر
على المستوى الذاتي والشخصي
الكثير من الأشخاص قالت لي:
"لماذا تقوم بهذا العمل الذي يستنفد
من وقتك وطاقتك وجهدك وتفكيرك؟ لماذا؟"
فيكون تبريري دوماً أنّ هذا
العمل يطوّرني ذاتياً وشخصياً
يأتيني الرد: "كيف ذلك؟!
كيف طوّرك ذلك على المستوى الشخصي
وأنت تعمل طوال الوقت
وتضيع وقتك بين الجمعيات
والتطوع وما إلى ذلك؟!"
دعونا نعود مرّةً أخرى إلى ذات النظريّة
ونفتح حساباً في مصرفنا العاطفيّ
حساباً لنا نحن
فعندما نقوم بأمرٍ جيّدٍ أو أمرٍ مفيد
للأشخاص من حولنا سواءً
للعائلة أو للمجتمع أو لأيٍّ كان
عندما نقوم بذلك فإننا نضع إشارةً موجبةً
ونضيف رصيداً إيجابياً إلى حسابنا
وبذلك يصبح رصيدنا
عند أنفسنا ولدى مصرفنا عالياً
وهذا الرصيد مهمٌ جداً،
لأنه الوقود الذي يدفعنا عندما
نكون في حالةٍ من الإحباط والاكتئاب
لأنه الوقود الذي يدفعنا
ويدفع محركات التحفيز والإبداع لدينا
عندما نكون بحاجة لذلك.
بعد كلامي هذا، في النهاية أقول:
من الممكن أن نقوم بأي شيء وأن نصل لأيّ شيء
ومن الممكن أن نقف بعد أيّ انتكاسةٍ تواجهنا
كلّ ما نحتاجه هو دعم الأشخاص من حولنا
وهذا الدعم يأتي من الرصيد الائتماني
العاطفي الذي بذلنا جهدَنا في تشكيله
بتعاملاتنا وطريقة تواصلنا وصدقنا.
شكراً
(تصفيق)